what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are finally covering infinity
or at least starting to cover infinity
this is a big story this is this is a
pretty huge story and it's amazing we're
gonna cover this and then bookend into
Infinity Gauntlet part 8
Thanos quest parts 1 & 2 and then the
lead-up to Thanos quest so technically
we're kind of doing this out of
chronological order but infinity is an
amazing story it is it is such a great
story now
this builds on everything we've talked
about so far with Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers we kind of
took a break from that for a little
while
the idea of Avengers and New Avengers is
that a debt with the collapse of the
multiverse right be basically the end of
all things this is one of those stories
that leads up to that and it's designed
to kind of give us this perspective that
like everything's popping off and
everybody's really panicking but
initially what this does is it actually
picks up with Titan now one thing I also
want to preface here if you are a little
bit out of if you haven't seen those
videos what we always fresh you guys as
we go through this but I would also
suggest you guys go back and watch those
videos because it'll it'll help to get
you caught up on everything that's going
on right now but we pick up on Titan and
what we do is we pick up with an
outrider now out riders are genetically
modified or really genetically
engineered beings that serve a singular
purpose and that purpose is whatever
whims and wants their masters want and
so what we end up doing is picking up
with Corvus glaive now right off the bat
we're not told this is Corvus glaive but
we know there's my virtue of the fact of
how he looks and really everybody's kind
of looked into him by now because of the
infinity war movie but what's really
happening is that this outrider shows up
and the questions asked where have you
been you know what what have you found
and the outright response that it found
a place called up called al Ghul oh and
when the questions asked have you found
the gauntlet or is there a tribute what
this indicates is that things are being
hunted for in two fashions this group is
looking for the Infinity Gauntlet or
they're looking for a tribute if the
Infinity Gauntlet is not offered and so
what this thing basically says is there
is no gauntlet there but there is a
tribute that will be offered and so as a
result the outriders sent back out again
to find another world and so what we do
is we pick up on this planet a lagoon
with Corvus glaive himself this is what
I love about Jonathan Hickman writing is
basically like like word spreads when
these conquerors returned word spreads
of Corvus glaive because river Corvus
glaive is hardcore now again this is
really like the first real appearance
that he has and notice this this guy is
so awesome he shows up at he asked
questions where's Agha Lux the brave
your your brain
warrior where's this man that will save
you from the doom that I'm going to
bring to your doorstep and when the
question when those response given by
the king well we don't know Corvus
glaive simply says I know where he is I
know where he is because you sent him to
kill me as soon as we got here so not
only did I kill him I've destroyed his
sword which is a ceremonial weapon for
you oh and by the way here's the arm he
used to hold it with this is hardcore
like they immediately summon the guards
right like the other King kind of freaks
out some of the guards chorus plays like
I think not you know and just like
that's not gonna happen at all and so in
response what is up happening what we
find out is that somewhere along the
line Thanos had shown up on this on this
world and just started like eradicating
people just sort of obliterating people
and put really push them to like the
brink of extinction and where there were
only a few thousand of them left what
they did is they rebuilt and so what the
alternative is a Corvus glaive offers
really the ultimatum offers is you can
give me a pittance or I will eradicate
what's left of your people and I will
destroy you in your entirety and so
ultimately they give in Corvus glaive
travels back to Titan he basically shows
Santos here's the tribute you're looking
for and we end up finding out it's the
heads of all the children that existed
on that planet
and so at this point we switch back to
earth you basically follow this outrider
as it's running through and as it's
trying to find what's going on I mean it
goes from place to place they can't see
it it's just jumping from person to
person trying to figure out what's going
on and trying to find this particular
object that is hunting for it now from
here we jump to another point in space
and what we have here are the builders
the gardeners in the ls now this is
Jonathan Hickman's way of retelling the
origin of the universe the issue with
this is that this is before Secret Wars
in 2015 after Secret Wars in 2015 the
origin of the universe was retold yet
again by a guy named Al Ewing in The
Ultimates line of comics would you'll
find that video video link down in the
description but basically before a Ewing
told his origin what this essentially
says is that there's basically the
builders they are these beings that are
responsible for the creation of all
things now again we talked about this in
the New Avengers video that we did
before but what basically is established
here is that the builders created
planets they created life everything
that exists inside of this universe was
created by the builders they live up to
their namesake now again none of what
we're seeing here really applies anymore
in terms of the role the builders play
that origin is effectively kind of been
wiped away as far as we're aware they
don't really exist anymore so you can
kind of take this for what it's worth I
mean the role they play is still cool
and it's
matters in the confines of this story
but in the greater Marvel landscape it
doesn't really matter anymore so it's
just kind of left to whatever it is that
you want to follow here but the idea is
that on this world of the builders are
currently raising and destroying we have
what are called space Knights now the
space and ice made their appearances
back in 1979 with ROM number one and I
do not remember who wrote that story but
they are basically cyborgs there are not
full machines instead what you had was a
group called the Dyer race which we
don't really get into for this video but
the space Knights are basically does not
designed as this sort of interplanetary
slash Galactic police force to a degree
but the idea is that they were basically
beings humanoid beings at one time that
were converted into these space Knights
and it's actually an honorable position
to take to offer yourself up and to be
accepted and become a space knight is
one of the highest honors that a
humanoid being can achieve in this part
of the universe but with them basically
being this more or less Avengers s kind
of super superhero team protecting this
world they're met by the arrival of
Captain universe now again this is all
part of that refresher stuff Captain
universe is it's really more of like a
concept that Bond's itself to a
particular person it's one of those
things where that the Kathleen universe
only ever really shows up when the
universe is in dire straits when the
universe is in danger there's some
massive threat that like universal power
requires but the whole idea here is that
where you have a few days on this planet
to kind of say look the space Knights
are here this speights Knights are gonna
rescue us it makes sense because of
space Knights have for the most part
been undefeated it's like The Avengers
right like you have different members of
the Avengers have fallen but by and
large the larger Avengers roster has
always succeeded the heroes always win
and that's the point of this the really
the whole collapse of the multiverse
story is to answer the question what
happens when the heroes don't win and in
this small confined space that's what
kept the universe tells these these
people here like sure you can cheer on
the space Knights all you want to
they're going to die and so are you this
world is going to be destroyed
how many question is why then the
response is because the builders are
here and that's when the builders say
let it be as if this planet never was
and everything gets destroyed the
planets obliterated innocent in its
entirety and so what we end up doing
here is we transition to a place called
the peak with a group called sword now
sword stands for the sentient world
observation and response department and
we've talked about this a million times
before
where shield exists to monitor earth
explicitly sword exists to monitor space
they basically monitor all these
different extraterrestrial races they
keep track of their radio chatter and
they basically keep an eye on things to
make sure that no one really
comes a credible threat to earth but if
in situations like this an alien race
shows up on earth then sword takes
precedence over shield and the result is
that were sword initially sent in their
own agents to deal with this ultimately
they ended up pulling their agents out
and they brought the Avengers instead
and when the Avengers show up on the
scene we end up finding out this group
of people who were here our Scrolls now
again scrolls are shapeshifters that's
really kind of the big the big claim to
fame with them is they can take on the
form of virtually anything they want to
and where the avengers are able to put
them down relatively quickly they start
to notice as something isn't right
usually whenever the scrolls show up on
earth there there is like a war group
designed to infiltrate the earth and
then try to take out humanity and take
over the earth
but we're Captain America and Hawkeye
and these various Avengers look around
what they start to realize is that if
this is not a war party and this is not
a scouting party there are soldiers of
any kind
they look like refugees and if they're
refugees what are they fleeing from
that's the question that's being asked
yes that's a question they're trying to
find an answer to and so picking back up
with this outrider that basically take
that that shows up on the city of
Attilan as it goes through and starts to
read the mind of Black Bolt it digs
further and further into his past and
digs further and further into figuring
out what Black Bolt is about and this is
when we start to realize that what it's
looking for is the Infinity Gauntlet but
where it does find the Infinity stones
which were controlled and really
possessed by the Illuminati for quite
some time this is group that basically
had like a hidden hand inside the the
event it took place in Marvel Comics
what it also learns is the Infinity
stones have been destroyed now again
this dealt with the collapse of the
multiverse this dealt with the idea that
when you had worlds crashing into each
other basically another universe
crashing into the main Marvel Universe
the Illuminati's response was gathered
the Infinity Gauntlet you gather the
Infinity stones we can literally use the
power of our universe to push that
universe away but the Infinity stones
shattered the time stone disappeared and
the gauntlet is basically defunct now it
doesn't work anymore and that's what the
outrider realizes there are no more
Infinity stones left they're all gone
but then suddenly Black Bolt wakes up
says get on my mind and then goes to
attack the outrider now where the
outrider tries to make its way out of a
tail and cuts through a few people here
and there ultimately Black Bolt catches
up to it uses this quasi sonic scream to
try to disable it but it ultimately ends
up getting away and so the question is
what is this thing why is it here and
why is it looking for the Infinity
stones and so at this point we jump back
to the peak we jump back to Captain
America and all these guys and this is
cool because remember when it comes to
the Earth's superheroes for the most
part they usually
earth-based but what you also have is a
character named Smasher now Smasher is
an earthly but she's the first earthling
to be inducted into the Shiar Imperial
Guard now we talked about this before
the Shiar empire is just a an
amalgamation of different races which
have all sworn fealty to like the
existing leader of the Shiar empire but
with the Shiar empire you have what's
called the Imperial Guard and the
Imperial Guard is basically some of the
hardest most intense and most capable
warriors that exist all across the face
of the universe and there they're drawn
from like all different facets of the
Shiar empire and even some are drawn
from beyond the Shiar empire but they're
basically exceedingly capable and with
smasher being a part of the the Shia
Imperial Guard that basically what she
says is your concerns are legitimate
where you're picking up all this radio
chatter and it's essentially every
single major empire that exists out
there in space that's recalling all of
its soldiers from every foreign battle
whether calling in every single ounce of
armed force they have the reason for
this is because something is mobilizing
in the universe that has the ability to
obliterate entire worlds the indication
here is that they're worried about the
builders the builders are going from
planet to planet blowing them up
destroying them in their entirety and
where the Avengers try to get a hand on
things what we end up finding out is
that if the builders show up on earth
and there's no one there to stop them
they will annihilate the entirety of the
planet and every single superhero on
earth will die and so this is a
mobilization it's an attempt by Captain
America and Iron Man and Captain Marvel
Carol Danvers to basically rally all the
Avengers together and then send them out
in space for the purpose of trying to
take out these builders before they
arrive on earth the problem with this is
we pick back up with Titan and when we
pick up with Titan we end up having this
out rider who shows back up again and
basically gives all this information at
Corvus glaive who's also met with
Proxima midnight black dwarf the ebony
maw and supergiant basically the black
order and when this happens what we end
up finding out is that the Infinity
gauntlets gone
the gauntlet itself is on earth but the
stones have been destroyed everything
except for the time stone and that this
planet can be offered as a tribute the
biggest caveat to this and the biggest
reason why this is so important is that
once we end up having Corvus glaive make
the declaration and ask the question to
Thanos where do you want us to go
Thanos says we want to go to earth the
various people here respond because
earth has a reputation a lot of places
hate earth they despise earth but they
also recognize some of those powerful
in the universe originated from earth
and so this is one of those things where
people look around and they say the
planet Earth is the place where villains
go to die like no one ever goes there
and comes out on top the heroes always
win if we go there with nefarious
schemes they will destroy us and they
will kill us and we'll just be another
notch in the belt but the cool thing
about this is a Corvus glaive says under
normal circumstances yes but I've
learned that there's discord in the
Inhumans oil family that the x-men are
experiencing a schism Rimmer we cover
the schism event where Wolverine and
Cyclops basically experienced a rift and
they split apart and launch their own
x-men schools the earth is in shambles
in a variety of ways all this comes out
of civil war but the most important
thing to take away from all this is that
the Avengers have left earth there are
no Avengers on the planet Earth it is
ripe for the picking now from here we
jump to the really like this this
massive battle that took place between
like the Avengers and the various
empires of the universe that we're
facing off against the builders and this
was kind of crazy because in this
particular battle that happened like it
was a massacre and it's interesting
because when the superheroes showed up
when the various Avengers and so on
showed up they found like what appeared
to be a paltry fleet that belonged to
the to the builders and maybe was one of
those things of like the builders had a
weapon that was just so powerful but if
they destroy the ship they destroy the
weapon and all the superheroes win and
so for the most part they kind of went
into it with with perceptions of
guaranteed victory but like the best
laid plans of mice and men what ended up
happening is a ruse was revealed that
what the builders had done as a had
basically cloaked a majority of their
fleet and so once the superheroes got in
there and once they were funneled into
the hot gates and they were boxed in the
fleet was decloaked and they were
massacred and the Avengers just like
almost anybody else who survived was
just fleeing for their life it was the
only thing that they could do now the
other half of this is that with Thanos
being given word by like Corvus glaive
and so on that basically the Infinity
stones had been lost and were the Kolob
City and said the only infinity stone
thus left is a time stone which vanished
Thanos simply said your job is to find
it I will worry about the Inhumans I
will deal with them and so again this is
cool because what is up happening is
Corvus glaive is initially sent to the
infamous but before we deal it Before we
jump into that what we end up finding
out is that like the Black Order when
they showed up on earth they wrecked
everyone the x-men done like those guys
are finished Atlantis was conquered by
Proxima midnight or I'm sorry the ebony
mark this is one of the coolest things
the ebony
is a really really powerful sorcery the
issue with this is that the every model
really really relies more on like
duplicitous and you know duplicity
and manipulation and what are you done
is he'd actually driven dr. strange to
summon Shue McGrath there were all these
things that went on but in Wakanda there
was a fighting chance because we're one
of the call obsidian showed up when were
conduct they were wrecked they were
absolutely devastated by Black Panther
and the wakandans which was so cool to
see I was like man this is absolute
beast
there are comics that deal with this
these various skirmishes and so on but
essentially what went on here is that by
and large with the exception of like a
handful of places here and there
everybody had been taken out like
everybody had been defeated and there
really was no hope left for anybody else
earth had essentially fallen and so what
is up happening is we pick up with
Corvus glaive who shows up at the
inhuman Royal City now again this little
tidbit takes place before Thanos you
know heads out and goes to deal with the
Inhumans himself but Corvus glaive shows
up and immediately starts talking trash
he's like hey guys so I was told there
was a king here but I can't seem to find
that King maybe it's because he's the
king of a small tiny little kingdom an
itty bitty Kingdom that's irrelevant
maybe that's why I can't find this king
just like talking some serious smack but
it's interesting because remember when
it comes to Medusa and Black Bolt Black
Bolt can't really talk he's got the
quasi sonic scream so if he were to like
utter a word it has the potential to
destroy an entire planet so as a result
of this Medusa basically speaks on his
behalf
now Medusa is not a pushover she's not
someone to be trifled with and she
simply steps up and says hey look you
know you didn't come here to talk all
the trash all you want to just be aware
many have tried and many have failed so
you can come here to a-tellin and you
can make your threats but you may not
walk out of that you may not walk out of
this alive but here's the caveat to this
the Cole obsidian loves death they
worship death in the same way that
Thanos does and so for them being killed
is a welcoming thing if you really
believe that death is something that we
fear if you're so foolish as to believe
that then let me help you understand
your place in the bigger picture and in
turn like he has his soldiers cut their
own throats just to show that they have
no qualms with die which means that any
and all control in each any type of you
know manipulation the Inhumans would
have had at their hands threatening them
with death and so on that it's all in
vain there's nothing they can do and so
when when the questions asked well then
what do you want here then Corvus glaive
simply says a pittance a tribute the
same thing he said
but this is when we started to find out
what it is the question is well what is
the pittance and the tribute that you
want well they Corvus glaive responds by
saying we want the heads of every child
that exists inside you're in human city
between the ages of 16 and 22 now notice
this this is specific it's not just all
the heads of your kids
it's the heads of the kids between a
certain age which means that they're
looking for something but this is kind
of cool because what is up happening is
it like like Corvus glaive says look you
have an alternative here like you have a
choice you can die a little or you can
die a lot
you can sacrifice the kids or we'll just
come back and kill everyone we've
already taken down virtually every
single city that exists all your
superhero teams are in pieces the
Avengers are in space there's no one
left to challenge us so you can be the
last man standing and you can be the
last man to die make whatever choice you
want to make you have 24 hours and we're
going to come back and when we do there
has to be an answer and so what we end
up doing here is picking back up with
really like the escaping members of the
Galactic Council
they're just fleeing for their lives
trying to get out of this this conflict
with the builders as fast as they can
and where they've all managed to make
their escape where they've all managed
to get away the remar shilling of forces
begins to come back into play again
because with the builders continuing to
be out there they have to be taken down
and the various superhero groups the
various interplanetary governments and
interplanetary soldiers and teams and so
on and so forth are all functioning as
part of a unified front to try to take
these guys down they find small
successes here and there and taking out
like different factions of the builders
armies but at the end of the day it
doesn't matter because what is up
happening is the gardener actually
healer just kind of kicks off the end of
the planet and just kind of sacrifices
his life but the result is that in doing
so with the destruction of one of these
beings what is up happening is like the
entire planet is basically sent into a
state of decay and disease meaning those
individuals who are left behind those
who are stuck here on this planet men
women and children alike they all just
succumb to illness and disease and death
they literally just exist in this
terrible circumstance of destruction and
so what ends up happening is you end up
having Black Bolt who basically summons
the rest of the Illuminati Black Panther
dr. strange Reed Richards name of the
Submariner iron man and beast breathed
them all together and essentially says
like here's what's going on Thanos is on
earth right now like while you guys are
out there fighting this battle in space
Thanos is on earth and Thanos is
invading Earth but Thanos is looking for
something particular he's looking for
one thing and when the question is asked
what is that black bolts like look I'll
deal with him am I
I'll deal with sadly I'll given my
answer in my city by myself but like
what he's looking for is his son that's
why he's here
Thanos is looking for his son so he can
kill him
alright so truth to tell infinity is
turning out to be a lot more popular
than I thought it would be man I didn't
realize you guys would be that excited
about it I didn't really plan on doing
any of the science I just plan on doing
like the main events and it like the
main story itself and it's kind of
talking about the times as we go through
it but like I'm looking at the comments
and looking at how many of you guys are
watching it and I'm just like okay so I
guess we will cover the tie-in with a
black order like crushes the earth
superheroes now this is this is cool
like it's it's one of the coolest things
ever like I love the call obsidian like
it's it's one of the coolest ideas like
having fan ozone order now one thing I
want you guys to bear in mind this this
the next video that comes out we
actually wrote a reference this because
I'm recording this after I recorded that
one but we'll make sure this fits in
terms of like the video playlist and me
being in chronological order all that
kind of good stuff but initially this
picks up with what the Cole obsidian has
learned that the Infinity stones are
basically gone now remember this comes
from the outrider this comes from that
out writer that showed up on earth and
it was looking for the infinity infinity
stones to the Infinity Gauntlet could be
reformed and of course once it reported
back its mind was red and we end up
learning what it is that's going on and
it's kind of interesting because the
Cole obsidian doesn't necessarily agree
with Thanos and Thanos his mind he is
looking to regain absolute power and
even like like supergiant is just kind
of like okay but there's only one stone
left there's only the time stone
remember we cover that in Hickman's
Avengers the New Avengers when he occurs
were happening Captain America got the
Infinity Gauntlet he tried to push one
of the other universes away and it
destroyed the Infinity stones everything
except for the time stone was shattered
and the time stone disappeared but
because of the fact that it's still
there Thanos his response is you only
ever really need one stone and that
makes you God not only that like what
this would do if they don't got the time
stone he could just jump back into the
path to the point when the Illuminati
presumably had the infinity gems he
could just kill them all take the
infinity gems jump back to the modern
day have a fully fleshed out Infinity
Gauntlet and retain godhood but remember
it's kind of cool because for Thanos
being God it is like it's like a drug
because over the course of its
publication history he's been God a
multitude of times the first time it was
the Cosmic Cube the second time it was
the
finiti gauntlet you know we saw a
handful of things going on if you read
Marvel the end he's had like the heart
of the universe the power of the one
above all and he destroyed the entire
multiverse with that without that kind
of power
Thanos has attained godhood in a
multitude of ways and even in his base
form without the Infinity stones
he's crazy powerful I mean he went
toe-to-toe against Galactus albeit
Galactus was in a relatively weakened
state but he managed to like hold his
own against Galactus a cosmic entity so
I mean there's a lot of power to be had
here and it's kind of interesting
because like like the ebony maw kind of
speaks up and is like look I mean sure
we could go for this but like there's
other things that we could focus our
efforts on but again this is an invasion
fleet attack the earth capture these you
know capture the Infinity stones those
are Thanos his direct orders and so what
happens is this conflict takes place in
a variety of different different areas
initially the the opening skirmish
really takes place in New York so you
have like Reed Richards you have iron
man Tony Stark and they're using
whatever technology they have at their
disposal
but you're talking about super advanced
technology the other part really comes
with like what conduct and this is cool
because black dwarf shows up on the
doorstep of black panther now let me
tell you something man what Conda is
where villains go to die only a fool
goes to Wakanda starting problems right
everyone loses like no one wins the only
person who really successfully won was
like Doctor Doom and like he started an
insurrection and that's one of the
things I want you guys to be aware of we
already covered the story from Hickman's
Fantastic Four where black panthers stop
being the quote-unquote king of Wakanda
and became the king of the Dead now a
little bit of a refresh here for those
of you guys who didn't see that Black
Panther was king of Wakanda for years
and years and years and years at least
T'Challa was but there came a point when
Black Panther was injured and then like
aqueous are really kind of seated the
throne to his sister Shuri who took over
the role of black panther the issue with
this is that we're - Charla would have
gone back to that role Doctor Doom
actually instigated an insurrection
inside of Wakanda allowing a handful of
really these insurgents to take over and
basically ask everyone including Sheree
and T'Challa himself now this whole
scheme by dr. doom was for the purpose
of acquiring all the vibranium stores of
Wakanda which he did and the result was
that in order for dr. doom to be
defeated because vibranium amplifies
magical energy black panther had to
render all vibranium across the world
completely inert but because of the fact
was believed that he had totally
shattered the economic standing of
Wakanda basically obliterated any and
all financial resources that they had
ultimately sure he maintained the role
of Black Panther and T'Challa became
King of the Dead but like supergiant
shows up on the doorstep of Black
Panther and unbeknownst to him gets
absolutely wrecked because why Panther
is a beast
that's why I do I love the way Hickman
writes Black Panther because he's like
hey man you know look you can come here
and you can pick a fight just just be
aware many have tried and many have
failed but from here we switch over to
Atlantis this is another thing that I
want to I want to kind of focus on here
I want to talk about for a second the
the animosity between name with a
submariner and black panther is only
ever has only ever really been a recent
thing I mean for the most part they were
kind of teammates and I mean they work
together from Tom at Han but the reason
why there was so much animosity at the
time this story was being written was
because of a story called Avengers vs.
x-men which we've covered and Avengers
vs. x-men saw a man with a Submariner
basically getting one part of the
Phoenix force which was also split among
Emma Frost of the x-men Cyclops of the
x-men Colossus and and his sister magic
the result is that name of the
Submariner launched an attack against
what conduct and destroy the entirety of
the Necropolis in the whole nine yards
so what cond is still in a rebuilding
phase but in response to this black
panther destroy the entirety of atlantis
like he's same as soldiers sent his
forces to atlantis invaded it and just
raised it to the ground and so at this
point atlantis is on the verge of
complete and total destruction
so when Proxima midnight shows up on the
doorstep of Maine with a Submariner and
says we're looking for the Infinity
stones tell me where they are or I'll
destroy what paltry little kingdom you
have left and so for name of the
Submariner to be told and Lantis will be
destroyed whatever little soldiers you
have left they'll be totally annihilated
I'll destroy you and everything that you
know and love then it's like okay I'll
do whatever I have to do in order to
make sure it Landis is safe but
vengeance is on his mind and so when the
question is asked by Proxima midnight
where is the Infinity stones where
should I send all these forces of Thanos
the responsive name of the Submariner is
him with conduct because that way it'll
see just the total destruction of black
panther and everything in Wakanda itself
but from here we move towards probably
one of the best parts of infinity we
moved to the ebony maw now I love the
ebony more oh my god I love anymore he
is such a great character the whole idea
is that he uses words to basically do
people into doing things but he's
basically ensnared dr. strange and
that's what's so cool about this
you're talking about like the master of
the mystic arts right like dr. strange
has for the most part over the course of
his life seen and done it all I mean you
have all kinds of characters out there
that dr. strange has to has had to
contend against that are insanely
powerful then you have someone like the
ebony MA and he just shows up and just
whispers things into the ear of dr.
strange and then suddenly he's ensnared
and so it's interesting and it's wild
because at this moment right now he's
basically just a pawn but at this point
we switch over to the Jean Grey school
now somebody else said I want you guys
to also be aware of the Jean Grey school
and really the x-men at the time this
story is written there basically in
shambles right like this comes out of
schism and we cover the Schism story
that was basically a story where
Wolverine and Cyclops had two distinctly
different views on what direction the
you know Xavier school for gifted
youngsters should go in and because they
had basically irreconcilable differences
they basically had their own little mini
Civil War and you had Wolverine who
broke off and formed the Jean Jean Grey
school of higher learning and then you
had Cyclops who stayed at the Xavier
school and they just ran two different
institutions but that's why you don't
see like the full brunt of the x-men
here it's basically just Wolverines
x-men team and cyclopses team isn't here
but showing up alongside supergiant and
Corvus glaive this is cool because
Corvus glaive is like the first of the
five right like he's like the first of
the of the Kol obsidian but like
supergiant is nothing to scoff at and in
fact supergiant actually goes through
analyzes all the powers of the mutants
who were here and says okay so you have
two types you have alpha mutants and you
have omega-level mutant the alpha
mutants don't worry about them the Omega
level ones are the ones we have to worry
about and that's true like we know that
from covering like the omega-level
mutant series you're talking about
mutants that have no definitive into the
power they possess it's basically
infinite and the first person she seizes
control of is Iceman because Iceman is
probably the character who's easiest to
use to basically freeze everybody up to
completely and totally take them over
but then suddenly you have Wolverine who
jumps in but the issue with this is that
as soon as he jumps into the fray he's
immediately impaled by Corvus glaive and
he's like done like you're you're done
you're finished man but I don't want to
tell you man but like you're done
there's there's nothing else with you
besides this whole thing like like
that's it and so the result is that
switching back over to Wakanda what we
end up finding out is like super Joe I'm
sorry not super John the black dwarf
just got wrecked like he was just he was
absolutely decimated but it's kind of
funny because we're Sheree and the other
members of Wakanda would relish in this
and celebrate Black Panther like
Charlie he's hardened like he's been
down this road a multitude of times
especially when it came to like ulysses
klaw and so the IV in his mind is they
weren't I mean sure they weren't really
looking for this kind of resistance they
weren't really expecting to show up here
and get absolutely select like
steamrolled by Wakanda but once they're
here they're looking for a thing in
particular and so they will come back
with a much larger force and that's what
he's concerned about and so what ends up
happening is that we pick up in the
aftermath of this right like we pick up
with thanasis ship sitting over at Ilyn
but it's kind of cool because you have
like the black dwarf you've got Corvus
glaive you got Proxima midnight you know
you have everybody except for the ebony
maw who basically show up here now
remember when it comes to Thanos and the
Black Order for the most part they're
given a lot of leeway
right like Santos is like here's my
instructions complete them I don't care
how you do it as long as you do not come
back here with failure that's basically
the rule and so they're kind of given
free reign and the epidemis no different
when Thanos looked at the ebony Maya he
basically says okay look his methods
aren't necessarily normal they're pretty
unorthodox but he gets results and at
the end of the day that's all I care
about because people are asking like
worse the ebony maw we can't communicate
with him telepathically he's not using
his communicator he's basically gone off
the reservation he's off the radar
entirely but Thanos isn't really worried
about that because the ebony ma always
gets results the issue with this is that
the other members are really the you
know Proxima midnight says look
according to name was a submariner he
told me that like the time stones in
Wakanda so we're gonna have to go to
Wakanda now Santos his response is cool
but I'm gonna go down to the to the
inhuman world city first I'm gonna deal
with them and we'll find out you know
where that extends to you in the in the
next video
but in this one it's kind of cool
because you know like the black dwarf is
like hey man look I'm really really
sorry I failed you know I'm sorry I
screwed up but I'll make up for it man
and that'll just like no no you will not
like you it like what I'm gonna smash
your head into the ground I'm gonna help
you understand your place in the bigger
picture and then you're gonna go sit in
a Cell and you're just gonna wait until
I call for you now this is a pretty
significant thing because for the call
obsidian one of the most important
things they can do is one please Spanos
and two if they please Stannis to hand
their lives over to death that's really
what they shoot for it but with Thanos
being displeased is like the ultimate
failure on their behalf they lose
respect of the other members you know
from the other members of they call
obsidian and so the result is that black
dwarf is is kind of an a pretty rough
spot for him and so what ends up
happening here is like the entire force
of Wakanda Black Panther Shuri all their
soldiers the whole nine yards are
basically forced to look on as Stannis
Vasia n-- fleet moves full on into
Wakanda Proxima midnight
Corvus glaive you know supergiant the
whole nine yards they all basically make
their move onto Wakanda and the question
is left here is what chance does Wakanda
have what possible hope do they have
against the entire brunt of Thanos's
armies combined with the black order
along with Thanos presumably showing up
after he's done dealing with the
Inhumans man I was looking through the
comments for the first infinity video we
did and like people were screaming at me
to finish the rest of it people were
just like you gotta finish infinity man
it is it is an amazing story it is so
good like I understand where you guys
are coming from but yeah okay so in the
first video like we talked about how we
had two stories going on at the same
time you have the Avengers in space
because you have the builders who are
just like this really ancient race who
were responsible for basically the
creation of everything and we're just
like running across the cosmos just like
obliterating all these planets and stuff
and so the Avengers like basically want
to go check it out at the request of
like the members of the Galactic Council
and so on so basically you have like
this army composed of all these empires
across the universe which had all banded
together for the purpose of trying to
take on these builders and they all got
deuced on like they all got Rhett they
just warm prepared and then like you had
Santos who invaded earth with the black
order and like they show up and they
crush everybody like almost everybody
look Honda is like the only country that
really succeeds in finding anybody off
because you know Black Panthers are
beasts so so like picking up with this
this whole battle that goes on with the
with the Avengers and the builders the
Galactic Council and everything like
it's really just a retreat right like
the first skirmish they engaged in they
were just crushed by the builders and so
what they ended up doing was taking
refuge on like a massive citadel of
sorts but the builders started sending
out all these sentient drones they were
just like destroying this facility and
it was a message right it was a message
going out to the universe you can run
you can hide but it won't last long we
will find you no matter where you go and
so what this did is it put all these
different races in a position where they
had to make a choice either they could
bend they could acquiesce and they could
give up to the builders or they could
fight to the death and die and like
almost all these empires you know every
single one of these races it admitted
span for thousands and thousands and
millions of years it was basically just
giving up the Centurions were the first
ones to fall the chameleons fell next
and then the creek now these are all
races that have appeared over the course
of various eras in in Marvel Comics now
this also still brings together the
to counsel of course you have Ron in the
accuser who speaks on behalf of the Kree
Empire and then you have people like
like gladiator of the Shiar and then
you've got Jason of Spartak the father
of Peter quill you've got all these
people who are just kind of banded
together and for the most part the
Avengers were never allowed into the
Galactic Council because everybody hates
Earth but this whole thing deals with
the idea of like Captain America
stepping in alongside Thor as an advisor
of sorts and really just like a handful
of the Avengers and everybody's speaking
as part of this galactic Council but
these are all the various empires that
exist all throughout space so you've got
the brood you've got the scrolls you've
got the Kree
Niles you have all these different races
that exist there and they're all
basically you know more or less saying
the same thing everyone except Captain
America the answer that's being given by
virtually everybody is no victory can be
found here the only real option we have
is to basically give up the Captain
America's response is but why though
like we can win all we have to do is
find a way to win this is kind of ironic
because Captain America is talking to
people who are part of our a part of
races and empires they were mature races
when humanity was fledgling when
humanity was just now emerging onto the
scene and so what Captain America says
is that at this point we have to find a
way to bolster our forces and when we
face off against the builders some of
our number were captured if we can
rescue them and rescue those who were
not necessarily part of our teams but
having captured anyway we can increase
our number in that capacity and it's a
smart move liberate innocent people
liberate refugees liberate the
superheroes and all of them will rally
to our side and that's what happens
Captain America and Thor says we need
bait we need somebody to go in there and
we need someone to dupe the the builders
into focusing on us so they don't look
at what's going on over here and that's
exactly what happens Captain America and
the Galactic Council send their ships in
and they just operate as bait they go in
they fight against the builders and the
builders see this asked why are they
here again like are they really wanting
to fight again and that's how it's
designed to come across be a distraction
take their attention away from what
you're really trying to achieve and what
we end up finding out is the builders
made a mistake the builders made a huge
mistake Navy it made a very very costly
mistake because once we get in there
once some of the forces of Captain
America's armies get in there then they
start liberating different Avengers one
of the Avengers they liberate is the
Incredible Hulk and let me
the incredible hole breaks out and just
starts crushing everything like
literally destroys the ship on his own
just starts ripping through every single
device again fine from there like the
immediately teleport him out but the
cool thing is that they still have to
destroy these other two weapon ships
that are controlled by the Builder so
they in turn send in Thor along with a
handful of other people and of course
they're able to pull it off by just
destroying things but what this does is
it brings in star brand now star brand
we talked about before right like it's
this idea that you have what's called
the wide event and the wide event was
basically an initiation that took place
that whenever there was like a massive
Universal threat really once every
generation a new person would be chosen
to be the star brand but it was one of
these things where they would have
however much power they needed for a
particular point in time it's really
kind of a caveat is one of those things
were just sort of sort of like here's a
character that lets me do whatever I
want to do at any particular point in
time but they're not omnipotent and
indestructible they can be destroyed but
star brand serves this purpose he
basically destroys a huge portion of the
Builder army which in turn like allows
some measure of the tide to turn but
again this is not the full brunt of the
Builder army this is just a portion of
it picking up with a tail and Thanos
shows backed up to the inhuman City
because remember Black Bolt the king of
the Inhumans was told you've got 24
hours when when Corvus glaive showed up
at the home of the Inhumans he said
you've got 24 hours either you pay the
gauntlet or you pay the tribute the
gauntlet is Thanos comes here and raises
this city to the ground the tribute is
you kill all of your kids between 16 and
22 and bring us their heads as proof
Blackwell says no he says no I'm not
killing any of our kids only that he
basically evacuates the entire like has
the the whole city of Attilan evacuated
so that when they show up there when
Thanos shows up there there's nothing
left the only exception is lockjaw and
Maximus the mad the brother of black
ball now Maximus the mad being here
serves a couple purposes the first is
that all of the Inhumans are going
through the teleportation device known
as Eldred who wasn't inhuman at one
point I guess it was uh yeah I guess he
was unless he went to the mist he
basically became a door that's almost
like the siege perilous that when you go
through it it takes you wherever you
need to be at that particular point in
time but Maximus the Madden and lock jaw
the teleporting dog are really the only
ones left and Maximus basically
activates a massive bomb underneath
Attilan itself so when Thanos shows up
Danice arrives and says look man you had
24 hours and you're 24 hours is up now
I'm famous man so like it's nothing for
me to destroy this place if I obliterate
the entirety of a talent for you it's
the
at times for me it's a Tuesday so we can
do whatever you want to do let you
doesn't matter to me ma'am tell me what
you want what you want to do do you want
to die or you just want to sacrifice
your kids and blackbolt just screams at
Thanos now old-school Black Bolt would
have probably obliterated the earth had
he screamed like this as loud as he
possibly cut but black bolts power has
been toned down over the years to make
his character one that can be defeated
for the most part I mean it depends on
what you're talking about for example
like if you read house of M he whispers
at the villain apocalypse destroys
apocalypse and wipes out what amounts to
about a hundred acres of land probably a
little bit more whereas if you have this
like he screams and not nearly as much
destruction happens so it really kind of
depends on what era you're talking about
now House of M Black Bolt was stupidly
overpowered like it was he was
criminally oaky it was insane but black
bolts screaming serves a couple of
purposes the first is to try to destroy
Thanos and the second is to activate the
Terrigen bomb to basically detonate this
terrigen bomb on earth now from here we
transition to a city called a rollin
which is basically hidden on earth now
this is very very important because
really up until this point there wasn't
really any such thing as like secondary
in human cities right like in Marvel
Comics you had a tiller and that was it
what at Elland did and how it functioned
was contextual for example Attila was
basically a hidden city on earth with
the Inhumans lived and it was that way
forever and ever and ever and then Paul
Shing is in jail II in 1998 wrote
Inhumans vol 2 they basically told this
12-issue story where Black Bolt tricked
his own people he literally orchestrated
an assault on a talent so that his
people would it would finally agree with
him when he says we need to leave earth
and so Attilan took up residence on the
blue area of the moon that led into the
events of war of kings when eventually
they inhale the Attilan took over the
entirety of the Kree Empire eventually
they came back they ended up you know
returning back to earth again and then
they just sort of reside above the city
of New York and they've been there ever
since but there have never really been
other inhuman cities this is really the
first time that we started to see Marvel
expand this now Jonathan Hickman really
did this for the sake of this story and
the reason why is because were you ended
up having like the main city of Attilan
where the inhuman royal family has
always resided there were members of the
royal family who defected or even you
know even just like other members of the
Inhumans society that basically broke
off but in this city of a role and what
you have is a shard of the Terrigen
crystals and what it does is it allows
this city to basically implement
terrigenesis among its own people but
once every generation and so the result
is that they hope that people walking
like the best minds or different
abilities or what-have-you but we pick
up with a guy named fame and fame is
basically just a healer that's really
kind of like the quote-unquote gift that
he has but the indication here is that
he's never actually been exposed to
terrigenesis he's really more of just
like a medic but he's not one of those
people who's been chosen for
terrigenesis what is up happening is
that when this bomb goes off the
Terrigen mists spread throughout the
world now for those of you guys who are
wondering and Marvel Comics right now
and especially the events of like
Inhumans vs. x-men why the Inhumans had
risen to prominence the way they did
this is the reason why this is the story
that saw the detonation of the Terrigen
bomb and the Terrigen mists spreading
throughout the rest of the rest of the
world and what Marvel did was actually
pretty cool because what you had was a
line of stories that came immediately
after this written by Charles Soule so
you had in humanity you had inhuman that
basically explored like the aftermath of
these these Terrigen mists spreading
throughout the world and all these you
know basically hidden Inhumans that
didn't know they were inhuman subtly
going through the process of
terrigenesis out in the middle of
nowhere in subway stations walking along
the street in office buildings and
Capitol buildings all throughout the
world leaders even became Inhumans not
realizing they were inhuman the entire
time the problem is that Marvel
squandered that and instead going into
all-new all-different marvel they pushed
the x-men into the background they try
to promote the Inhumans which everybody
knows doesn't work because nobody really
cares about the Inhumans and so because
of this like with this bomb going off
Thanos is like okay man so like that's
your answer your answer is that you want
to fight them we can fight just be aware
man like when you fight me I fight to
the death I'm probably gonna kill you
because like you've irritated me and
that's just what's gonna happen so we
sort of like amelie he starts screamin
right he's like where's my son tell me
where my son is because he knows the
Inhumans know the location of his son
but he won't like blackball won't give
it up now of course at this point
pretense is out the window
Thanos that basically lied to the black
order saying well it's just it's a
tribute is what it is these are the
things I demand just do what I tell you
to and don't ask questions now Black
Bolt figured out earlier on there the
whole subtext was that Thanos was
hunting for Sun and because Black Bolt
knows that and Fano snows Black Bolt
knows that then we're just throwing all
pretense out the window and is just like
okay you know that I'm here looking for
my son tell me where my son is and if
you don't tell me I'm going to destroy
you and I'm gonna destroy everything you
care about now what this does is it
leads in to one of the most beastly
moments in the history of comics dudas
it's one it's like one of the greatest
Thanos moments of all time
black ball goes to scream if they are
just like you know what dude enough man
if this is how it's gonna be
he's like fine then man like keep your
secrets carry them with you to the grind
like smash his head in the ground I'm
just like dude
Thanos how beast are you like knocks out
Black Bolt in one hit and he's like fine
if there's now it's gonna be the like I
will find my son myself and I'll kill
him myself
that boy's gonna die and with Fame
having undergone terrigenesis that his
and human genes are activated and
suddenly his powers begin to emerge
although he doesn't really have control
over it now at this point man this
matters when the story gives manners
when the story just so good for fans if
you are a fan of Thor now is your time
to shine because what happens if Thor
shows up right like like you have the
the builders who are on Cree and like
Captain America is like okay so like
basically we have to surrender like we
have to give up so they send a guy to
Tikrit right now to the Crete world of
holla and like the you know Romani
accusers is is like there is you know
Captain America and US forces they're
sending an emissary here to basically
surrender to give up to you guys and so
Thor shows up and Thor's talking to this
builder they're told look you can't be
arms the boys like whatever throws his
hammer into the skies as the okay fine
on my own
so the builders talking to them Thor's
like look I came here to discuss terms
of surrender and the builders like no
there are no turns there's you give up
and you take a knee or like I kill you
and then we destroy the rest of your
allies so like what's it gonna be
and so like it's crazy right because
like while this is happening like
everybody's praying like all the
accusers are there and like the Galactic
councils watching this like all eyes are
on Thor so those like take a knee and so
Thor just kneels Thor Thor kneels down
he's like okay fine I surrendered we
take a knee and so like it's funny
because the Builder starts talking trash
right he's like humanity's place is to
take a knee like your place is below us
we're builders people don't want you
here like no one wants you here so we
are going to do the universe of favor
and we're going to eradicate you
suddenly they hit like there's there's
this thing like you know you're with AI
Captain America those guys they're like
they're like hey gladiator like we have
incoming and he's like what is it in
Captain America's like it's a reckoning
it's what it is Thor's hammer comes
flying back down BAM it goes punch it
right through this building punches a
hole right through my Captain America's
like you got them if they can be broken
they can be killed that's it they're
like we can destroy these guys we can
kill builders they're not indestructible
they're highly durable but they're not
indestructible and so Thor is like all
right huge stories like run in the
accuser got a question for you and Ron
is like what's up he's like do you have
free men and women here and Ron is like
yes it was like do these freedom of free
men and women will they fight for what
they believe in
Ron
says yes Thor rallies the entire Kree
are me to their son an army of thousands
and thousands of people rallies them all
and says it's time for battle and
Captain America is responsible when the
question is asked my gladiator like what
comes next Captain America's responses
now we went now we finally take back the
universe okay so we are concluding
infinity where we're finally wrapping
the story up and and god I love infinity
so much you know what I might do what
we've done with like blackest night and
brightest and like kind of stuff and
just like combine this into one big
video I think it's a cool idea because I
know there are some of you guys who were
just kind of like I want to see like the
whole thing innocent priority so I do
kind of like I think we might start
doing that from now on like whenever we
do like videos where were things are
like split into sections and then
combine it into one big video like once
we're done but the cool thing about this
is we basically pick up with the
Avengers coming from space and showing
back up on earth with all these groups
showing up here having allied themselves
and coordinated themselves with Captain
America arriving on earth for the most
part there's two battles that take place
one of them is out in space and the
other one is basically trying to like
punch a hole for Captain America and his
guys to get through and that's what
happens Captain America and US forces
are really like Thor and Hyperion
Incredible Hulk Carol Danvers you know
Captain Marvel Captain America they
basically finally managed to make their
way back to earth and when they do it's
okay we have to organize this now in
truth with the way that Jonathan Hickman
wrote this you could have like the
guardians of the galaxy who arrived and
like all the forces of Thanos are
destroyed but remember when it comes to
the planet Earth
it's an Avengers world it's a place
where like the Avengers keep the place
taking care of because this is basically
just the story of the Avengers versus
Thanos and that's what it boils down to
but it's kind of fighting for the
protection of Earth which is cool now of
course we The Incredible Hulk being here
you gotta bring out your big guns right
I mean you're talking about Thanos it's
something that you kind of have to kind
of have to do it and it's cool because
one thing to bear in mind is that in
Marvel Comics Thanos has kind of like a
not really a fear of the Incredible Hulk
but recognizes the dangers of the whole
we saw that in the Thanos vs. Hulk story
where we're at Thanos - basically said
look like I've always avoided fighting
The Incredible Hulk
because his strength is limitless and so
when it comes to the Hulk as a character
he's one of those guys where if you
don't have the ability to like take him
out immediately like as soon as the Hulk
emerges he'll just keep getting angrier
and angrier and eventually will just
overpower you it's just kind of how the
character works and so Captain America a
me
send him out and says get out there do
your thing be a distraction tear up as
much stuff as you possibly can now the
other half of this is we have the
Illuminati right like Black Panther and
Doctor Strange and Reed Richards and
Ironman and so on then with a submariner
and they're all basically here at that
Acropolis in Wakanda the city of the
Dead in order to try to find a way to
stop the bomb from being diac are being
activated by supergiant the issue is
that when they get there the bombs
already set in motion has already been
activated it's just waiting for a
trigger but supergiant has also seized
control of Black Bolt now remember we
talked about this before right like
old-school Black Bolt from like the 70s
and 80s his voice could shatter planets
his power has been reduced over time now
in terms of how Marvel justifies this in
the modern day what they basically say
is like the detonation of the terrigen
bomb helped to reduce the powers of
black ball exactly how I don't think is
really specified but basically that's
kind of the art the explanation this
offer the sort of scenario that's given
here but the long and short of it is
that for the most part like the armor of
Tony Stark and Doctor Strange of the
various you know capabilities they have
they can for the most part withstand the
full might of black bolts voice beasts
would be totally destroyed but because
of the fact that the armor of Tony Stark
gives him really enhanced durability in
a lot of different ways Doctor Strange
can use whatever spells he needs to and
then with a submariner
it's just highly durable because of the
fact that he's basically a mutant in
Atlantean and mutant hybrid what this
means is that beast is really the only
one who wouldn't who wouldn't stand much
of a chance and so of course you have
Namor push beasts out of the way and
that is really really cool here because
dr. strange sort of chimes in and Doctor
Strange basically says look like you
guys have pushed us to the brink time
and time again wanting to see what
happens wanting to see how far we fall
so if what you want to see is oblivion
if what you want to see is the abyss
then allow me to oblige allow me as the
sorcerer supreme to bring to life your
worst nightmares and so what we end up
doing is jumping directly to the inhuman
Royal City of all wrong we pick back up
with Thanos and this is cool because
Thanos being here with what's left of
the Black Order meaning that like black
dwarf has basically been defeated he's
pretty much out of the picture and then
you've got supergiant with the
Illuminati all you really have left here
is Proxima midnight Corvus glaive if the
ebony maw and of course stain the son of
Thanos who's held in stasis but it's
cool because they know starts to talk
about how life is sort of meaningless
and and the usual rigmarole that he
usually you know that he goes through
and then suddenly they met with the
arrival of the Incredible Hulk
now if Thanos punches the Hulk out of
the way but keep in mind then and notice
this Thanos does not
eally jump into battle with the
Incredible Hulk and again there's a
reason for this
he sends Corvus glaive and he sends
Proxima midnight to deal with the Hulk
because for the most part they can hold
their own against against the Hulk
himself and this comes by way the fact
that by the various powers that they
have especially Proxima midnight using
her abilities to force him back into his
Bruce Banner form what this means is it
leaves the field open for Thanos to deal
with whatever comes next
and what comes next is Captain America
Hyperion Thor and Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers now in the crop allah switching
back over to the necropolis of dr.
strange what we end up finding out is
that he actually starts to bring out Shu
McGrath not completely but partially the
Shu McGrath is an interesting concept
and we've never really talked about him
before we have insofar as like the many
angled ones but like Shu McGrath was
actually yanked out of his native
dimension by dr. strange and brought
into the main Marvel Universe as part of
infinity we didn't cover that section of
the story because there's a small set of
events it takes place with like Luke
cages Mighty Avengers but that's really
about it but it is cool because Shu
McGrath is far less powerful in the main
Marvel Universe than he is in his native
dimension and is even hypothesize
depending on what story you're talking
about that like Shu McGrath can never
actually be defeated and like Galactus
Shu McGrath appears to any given race
based on how that race would perceive
him so it's kind of an interesting thing
but still it is cool because ultimately
you have like Reed Richards who sort of
uses his powers to stretch and kind of
intervenes and starts binding in and and
basically separates Black Bolt from from
super giant who's just mentally
controlling Black Bolt himself and so
from there it's kind of cool because
what we end up getting is like like
Black Panther sort of trying to speak to
supergiant say look you're wasting your
time here like this is preposterous I
don't know why you're trying to set this
bomb off because you're gonna destroy
everything and everyone but like your
goals and your schemes won't really come
to fruition like you're gonna kill
yourself here you know and that's what
that's again the theme is constantly hit
on when it comes to the black order
something else said I want to hit on to
you because somebody mentioned this in a
comment in the last video in the in the
movie infinity war black dwarf is
actually gonna be called a call obsidian
like like Marvel changed his name for
the movie the Cole obsidian is the name
of the black order Thanos calls the
black order they call obsidian the black
order call themselves the black order
because they think it sounds cooler but
still like like the black order like
they desire death you know every single
member of the black order the Thanos
appear to especially here with
supergiant was at a moment in their life
when they crave death when they
basically wanted to die
and Thanos his response was I will give
you what you wish I will give you death
but you will have to fulfill a task for
me first that's how he works
because rubra Thanos has an affection
for mistress death he loves the idea of
death
he's Annihilus and so the result is that
when these various people were in this
point he just kind of used that as a way
to this kind of shanghaied them into his
own order and then in turn they carry
out his schemes in the hopes that he
will free them from life so to speak now
again it's cool because switching back
over to our own this is when you really
start to get like into the nitty-gritty
of the ebony maw and this is why I love
the ebony maw so much not just because
of the fact that like the name is
amazing dude I love the name the ebony
maw like I love that name so much it is
so cool but it's also because like like
look at the things he says see this is
why the ebony maw is so awesome no real
powers to speak of but like look at the
things he says I mean basically talking
to Thane it's like look at what you're
watching here you're watching the
Earth's Avengers the earth superheroes
fighting off against the cull obsidian
and sure they might defeat the coal
obsidian and in fact for the most part
they do but you have like some of the
most powerful beings in the universe
Carol Danvers Captain Marvel Thor The
Incredible Hulk Captain America you have
some of the greatest heroes in the
history of the planet Earth and even
some of the greatest heroes across the
universe and what they're doing is
getting rekt why because there's two
kinds of people in the universe those
who know that with Thanos comes death
and those who are so foolish to believe
that if they pray to the sky to a god
that's up there listening that maybe
that God will spare them from the wrath
of a Titan of Thanos his caliber maybe
they'll be safe but they're foolish for
believing so with Thanos
comes death death is always there to
follow only a fool believes they stand a
chance in the in the face of Thanos
might and that's what's so cool about
this because like it's what we would
expect like what you're seeing here with
Thanos just like juicing all over earth
superheroes that's gonna be infinity war
fur fur the earth superheroes it's it's
the end of times for Thanos it's a
Tuesday like it's not a huge deal it's
just kind of like whatever man you know
this is what I do I destroy things
so like either you can just be one of
the many people I've killed or you can
get out of my way but that's what we
would expect
now again something else that takes
place is it is kind of cool dealing with
like super Giants she's kind of whisked
out of the picture pretty fast
you have heard hunting for the trigger
more or less and then Maximus the mat
appears rather a bag of Black Bolt now
Maximus the mad is kind of interesting
because he's an on-again-off-again
villain he's one of those characters
where he does whatever he needs to
to satisfy his own in so think of him as
like an inhuman version of Loki in a lot
of ways and because of this when he
appears to two super giant he has a
trigger in his hand and says look if you
do what I ask then I'll give you this
trigger I'll give you whatever you know
I'll give you what it is that you seek
and the response is okay like like what
are you know what are you looking for
and what he says is the same is the same
thing I always want to basically be the
smartest person in the room that's the
only thing I ever really want and I'm
proving that now because you forgot
about the most dangerous thing in the
room and so what ends up happening is he
basically triggers the bomb and in the
moment when the bomb is triggered locked
jaw the teleporting dog teleports the
bomb and super giant away and then
teleports back and super giant gets
blown to pieces it's so cool and it's so
smart like it's pretty funny but super
giant of courses is ultimately destroyed
but again transitioning back to like to
Thames with the Illuminati and all his
forces showing you and interning the
show back up to where Captain America is
to help in the fight with Thanos with
the ebony MA talking to Fame again it's
so cool and this is what I love so much
about this is it's basically like look
only a fool would believe they have a
chance to live against a being of a
fantastical abhar who worships death
with Thanos comes death it's an absolute
rule of the universe but when you end up
having a Proxima midnight who of course
throws her various weapons at Captain
America with Captain America's shield
being powered by freedom actually
because of the fact that it's so durable
with you know being kind of a adamantium
iron vibranium alloy of course the
energy signatures basically dissipate
and one of them hits Corvus glaive and
so Corvus glaive is essentially
incinerated in his entirety by an
additional attack that comes from
Hyperion now this is something to
remember about Corvus glaive for those
of you guys who have seen my recent
videos with model now 2.0 in Thanos vol
1 right off the bat you're probably
asking yourself the question if Corvus
glaive is is toward here then how did he
show up a model now to point out
okay so Corvus glaive if you notice
always carries a staff so long is that
staff is never broken an intact Corvus
glaive can never truly be destroyed his
essence will live on and he'll just be
reconstructed that's kind of how that
works and so as a result you suddenly
have like what's left of the superheroes
facing off against against Thanos and
that's that's what's cool because you
suddenly have like Thor who jumps into
the frame and it's interesting because
like you look at this you're like oh
yeah man Thor Thor's callin down the
Lightning because you know god of
thunder and all that cool stuff Thor's
got this man right
wrong like
it's wretch like it's amazing Thor gets
crushed so bad it's it's hilarious
this is Thanos we're talking about and
just in like a base form no Cosmic Cube
no power stone no Infinity Gauntlet no
none of that stuff he's more than a
match for the Earth's superheroes and
where Thor comes riding and hi
nothing happens like the annals just
beats the crap out of it and that's
that's that's the cool thing to take
away from here because the whole time
this is taking place the ebony maw is
whispering in the ear of thane this is
how he works this is how he functions
duplicity manipulation this is how he
makes a name for himself deal every mom
is looking at Thane and saying look upon
my works and frown because only oblivion
waits those who are so foolish as to
believe they have a chance to succeed
against Thanos but if someone doesn't
step in they're all going to die and so
this is your opportunity thing this is
your chance are you going to run from
the idea of being the son of Thanos are
you going to take off from your destiny
are you gonna run and hide in the hills
or are you going to actually do
something are you going to become the
son of Thanos and that's exactly what
Fame does he finally steps up and says
yes and basically uses hand uses uh uses
his right hand I think it is to
essentially encase Thanos in living
death to basically encase him in amber
and he'll never be able to escape
Proxima midnight is in the exact same
situation
they're basically stuck here now this
goes forward into the future of Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers and
time runs out storyline and eventually
they are free that's where the Cabal of
name where the Submariner comes from and
that's why you see fan OHS in the future
of Avengers and new Avengers and going
into like Secret Wars and the collapse
of the multiverse but that's what this
is designed to do it's designed to
basically take the power and you know
take Thanos as a character and put him
on the back burner so that hickman can
come back and return him and have him
continue on but in the rest of the
Avengers a New Avengers story from here
it's just kind of like rebuilding right
is Captain America and it's Hyperion and
Carol Danvers and all these folks
basically rebuilding it's the world
coming to grips of the fact that like
Inhumans arising in a prominence now
it's the other universes across the
cosmos recovery rebuilding their
respective empires all that kind of good
stuff but for the Illuminati for the
name of the Submariner fur for Ironman
for Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four
for beasts for black panther for dr.
strange the collapse of the multiverse
continues on the incursions continue on
and while Thanos has been defeated he's
just one small conflict the rest of
everything is still going to continue on
you're still going to have the clout
the multiverse you're still gonna have
the incursians not only that where they
basically face-off against Thanos in
this regard and they've had to like
focus on the idea of presumably facing
their own mortality what they've also
got to contend with is other universes
now they've got to contend with the
black priests the ivory Kings all this
stuff that goes into like the collapse
of the multiverse and the end of all
things but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comment explain
it make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]